today I'm revealing the title and cover
of my brand-new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps it is
available for pre-sale at daily wire.com
slash Bennett's daily wire.com
slash Ben here's what's important about
the book the country is falling apart we
all know this I mean the country was
falling apart months ago before
coronavirus the corona virus pandemic
has really exacerbated a lot of the
divisions that undergirded what was
happening before what we are watching
right now is at least half the country
really does not see America as a
cohesive unit it doesn't see America as
an idea doesn't see America as a nation
instead America is a set of competing
interests America is just a bunch of
groups that hate each other and whoever
grasps the brass ring of power is able
to cram down their viewpoint on
everybody else why exactly is the
country falling apart I think the
country is falling apart because there
are a lot of people who want to
fundamentally change the country and
then there are some people who see that
America was meant to be unified that
America is based on a shared philosophy
it's based on a shared culture it's
based on a shared history and that's
really what the book is about you can
see in the Democratic primaries how much
of the Democratic Party does not believe
that we have a shared philosophy does
not believe we have a shared culture
believes that America's history is
actually a history of innate evil and
horror and how many Democrats today are
trying to use the pans that makes a
quote/unquote remake America Bernie
Sanders had a whole piece in the New
York Times where he was talking about
how we need to fundamentally reshape the
free markets and capitalism in America
it's a hope you see the sort of stuff
from Nancy Pelosi wanting to reshape
America on the back of a pandemic
Hillary Clinton says let no good crisis
go to waste the fact that people want to
fundamentally remake America and that
has really become the dominant ideology
of the political left and more than
anything else it's not just the
left-right division it's a question of
whether we stay together as a country
there's a traditional what I call
unionist history to the United States a
traditional unionist philosophy a
traditional unionist culture and that is
the idea that America does have these
shared things this shared philosophy and
that philosophy can be summed up in the
Declaration of Independence the idea of
pre-existing rights rights that
pre-exists government god-given that are
to be protected by a government that is
designed also not to invade those rights
with delegated powers that is answerable
to the people right these are the
traditional philosophies of the United
States the philosophy then limited
government ought to be combined with
powerful social institutions right the
institutions that inculcate
duty and virtue this was the traditional
American idea and then there's a group
of people that I call the disintegration
us and the disintegration is make the
case there is no shared philosophy but
actually America is just a brutal
vicious terrible place and really rights
don't exist
they're just privileges from the
government at the Wrights things like
the right to free speech or the right to
a free press or the right to assembly
these are actually just evil ideas that
are really designed to reinforce power
hierarchies the power of free speech the
rights of free speech is bad because it
allows people like you or me to talk if
the rights of free speech were good it
would actually bar people that are not
on the Left from talking
we'd have hate speech regulations you
see this with regard to the to the
belief that America's limited government
is is insufficient that we need to
overthrow the boundaries of the
Constitution people on Left are
constantly attempting to overthrow the
bounds of the Constitution or to
maximize the power of government we
don't have a shared philosophy that
shared that that philosophy was
originally constituted by rich white men
in order to reinsure on their own
interest so without that philosophy we
fall apart because then government is
just a power tool to be used against
whoever you don't like and then there's
the question of a shared culture yeah I
mean we all watch the same movies we all
watch the same TV shows what I really
mean is that there used to be an idea in
America that we had a culture of Rights
virtually all of our arguments were
based in this idea of Rights the right
to free speech the right to express your
opinion the right to worship as you saw
fit and act as you saw fit without
anybody else impinging on those rights
now this is not a law issue right now go
under sort of the philosophy
categorization this is an issue of the
culture and that is we are completely
intolerant of other people's right to
free speech at this point we try to
create boycotts we social media mobbing
has become the order of the day the
attempt to destroy people who disagree
with us not just debunk their argument
but destroy them as human beings come
after them go after their sources of
livelihood the attempt to completely
rewrite science in the name
things like sensitivity and feelings all
of this goes under the destruction of a
common culture without that common
culture we're not even speaking the same
language to each other
we're not even capable of communicating
properly with one another if we don't
share that culture and then finally
there's the question of American history
the traditional unionist version of
American history is very simple America
has had horrible periods in American
history but America's founding ideals
were great and good and the story of
American history is an attempt to
perfect those ideals and to strengthen
those ideals in the face of
countervailing disintegration as forces
that see America as a series of interest
to be torn apart at will that see
America basically is just a question of
power dynamics now this is the sort of
Howard Zinn version of American history
the founders were evil rich white
slaveholders who attempted to enshrine
their own own interests that that
America is rooted in slavery this is the
16:19 project from the new york times
and then there's the traditional
unionist history that says we're all
part of the same team and we weren't
always part of the same team because
America's ideals were not properly
construed and properly enacted but that
doesn't mean the ideals were wrong in
the first place America's story is a
story of progress of an upward
trajectory in terms of how we've
realized our our own visions of
universal human value the disintegration
is by contrast a that America's history
is really just quite evil and bad across
the board from foreign policy to
domestic policy and that means that we
have nothing to share right if we don't
share for last fee if we don't share
culture if you don't share history it's
very easy to divide the country and the
purpose of all that sedition is so that
we can rebuild something different in
the woods now here's this the dirty
little secret nothing different will be
rebuilt in the roads nothing instead
what will happen is we'll all go our
separate ways the groups will separate
what will revert to tribalism and that's
what we're seeing right now when
everybody is busy talking about Trump
the real question is not about Trump
it's been
a group of people who believed America
was never great and a group of people
who believed that America was always
great even if we didn't always fulfill
our potential but that is the real
battle that is happening right now we
need to restore what it was that made
America great in the first place what
are the ideas what was the culture we
need to restore our vision of American
history that's the way we're gonna
restore it the country so my book is
about America it's about our economy
it's about our values about our churches
it's been our constitution about our
declaration and about the people who are
trying to get rid of all of those things
in favor of building a new utopia my new
book how to destroy America in three
easy steps can't wait for you to read it
go check it out in presale right now at
daily wear comm slash Bennett that's
daily wear comm slash gun